hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich habe seit einem halben jahr
nicht mehr auf ebay fans reagiert eine
serie die damals noch wöchentlich auf
meinem kanal stattgefunden hat und der
grund dafür ist ganz einfach dass ich in
den letzten monaten dazu nur mannschaft
videos hochgeladen habe und auch keinen
richtigen content gefunden habe für
diese serie doch nun war ich mal wieder
ein bisschen im internet unterwegs und
ich habe so geisteskranke fans gefunden
von der wirklich sagen staaten direkt
mit diesem hier bei dem ein audi q7 suv
verkauft wird und ein interessent
schreibt tauschen sie auch gegen einen
rasen trecker kann in lübstorf abgeholt
werden sehr geehrte damen und herren
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
wollen sie einen rasen trecker gegen ein
17.000 euro teures auto tauschen und wir
sollen den trecker abholen
mit freundlichen grüßen ja ist ja aus
gold das rot das funktioniere ja okay
sagen sie mir eine gute preise nicht
werde kaufen 540 euro kann ich noch
machen ok haben sie auto waren sie mir
das bringen ich werde ihn noch fünf euro
zahlen weil ich habe eine kleine baby
und keine auto bekommen sie ich komme
also gute deutschland bosnien
kürzeste entfernung zwischen deutschen
und bosnien bis zehn stunden bis man
bossen hier verkauft jemand einen
philips fernseher und ein potenzieller
käufer schreibt dem verkäufer hallo ich
kommen für 100 fragezeichen zeug das ist
mir viel zu wenig der fernseher ist ein
sehr guten zustand da musst du nun mehr
bieten
okay okay was ist eine tief traurig
verlassen und den kinder wird gekommen
[Musik]
sein könnten sie noch mal fotos und
anderes licht waren erkenne die farbe
relativ schlecht da weil ich bin an der
arbeit getragen hatte die oberfläche ist
so ungefähr tief das hat er um 14.30
geschrieben und dann schreibt er eine
neue nachricht um 21 uhr 16 namens hi
der tisch ist gerade mit meiner frau
zusammengebrochen
es steht die gespräche nicht mit
übrigens auch unfassbar leid dass meine
stimme so geisteskrank am arsch ist
allerdings ich produziere ein bisschen
videos von bisschen später vorgestern
wurde die tal den europameister und ich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja ich hab's ausgiebig gefeiert dass
italien gewonnen hat wenn ihr jetzt
nochmal sehen wollt folgt mir gern auf
instagram da kommen jeden tag muss paris
ich würde allerdings erst mal
weitermachen mit dem nächsten ebay fällt
denn jemand verkauft hier einen stuhl
und fabio hat interesse an dem stuhl
der verkäufer schreibt daraufhin fabio
wann möchtest du es abholen jetzt jetzt
kann ich nicht jetzt kannst du eventuell
einen termin ausmachen anstatt immer
jetzt zu schreiben ja dann möchtest du
es abholen
jetzt warf er den stuhl eigentlich
abholen kauft jemand einen fliegenpilz
beschriften liefen
[Musik]
so was halt wirklich ihr verkauft die
man einen kühlschrank und ein
interessent schreib würde dir zehn euro
anbieten liebe grüße bei 15 euro können
sie die gerne haben zehn euro oder gar
nicht an gar nichts für sie war halt den
scheiß gehört und parkbuchten wenigstens
gar nicht den kuchen
[Musik]
was ist letzter bringt deutschland hat
er zeit im prinzen aber es gibt ihn 1976
in bremen geborenen georg friedrich
prinz von preußen kommt dem jahr rechne
ich hoffe dass ich ihnen behilflich sein
konnte
frage zeigte einige leute da sind so
lässt verkaufte mich wird ein bmw f11
520d ich gestärkt bei bmw fick dich
nicht mehr durch mit diesen ganzen
modellbezeichnungen 230 man auch kennen
sie mir dass modelle voller häufig 63
amg modell aber die sind gar keine 6,3
liter mehr ist aber auch ein anderes
thema freunde auf jeden fall schreibt ja
interessant 3.000 mehr nicht ihre
nachricht konnte nicht zugestellt werden
da anfragen als ganze sätze formuliert
werden müssen 3000 mehr nicht ihre
nachricht konnte nicht zugestellt werden
da anfragen als ganze sätze formuliert
werden müssen hallo ich würde 3000
bieten mehr nicht so wie ich in der
schule damals wenn ich gestehe mir geht
es sehr gut sehr gut geht es wie hier
schönen guten tag ich suche für meine
freundin und mich einen schönen platz
zum leben ich habe mir ihre wohnung
angesehen und wäre sehr daran
interessiert mit freundlichen grüßen
guten morgen leider möchte meine
vermieterin lieber alleinstehende
personen als mieter haben trotzdem noch
viel erfolg bei der suche das war für
mich auch kein problem
[Musik]
einfach mal für die wohnung dann mit der
freundin schluss machen alles ist als
nächstes verkaufte jemand auf ebay ein
brandneues sony handy für 400 euro und
ein interessent schreibt ihm hallo guten
tag ich würde das soli für 30 euro
kaufen wenn sie paypal haben und der
verkäufer ist halt was humor angeht auf
jeden fall mit am start und schreibt
daraufhin einfach 30 ist ein bisschen
viel
wie wärs wenn ich ihnen das handy
schenke und dazu noch 20 euro
draufpacken können sie es an mich
schicken adresse ist und könnten sie mir
bitte noch die sendungsnummer schicken
egal
das hier ist die definition von ironie
und das hier ist dein humor hier
verkauft jemand wieder so ein bmw 4340
modell dings auto aber es ist wirklich
ein modellauto also es ist kein
richtiges auto das versteht der
interessent allerdings nicht so ganz und
schreibt daraufhin warum so günstig
kaputt nein ist ein fairer preis möchten
sie mehr zahlen nein hat noch tüv
probefahrt möglich haben sie die
beschreibung gelesen worum es hier geht
das ist ein modellauto suche das model
ich suche
ich bin mittlerweile so lang single
alter bald werde ich ein album hier
verkauft jemand einen ziemlich traurigen
bmw 320d lcv wofür steht jetzt schon
wieder das lc idee ja auf jeden fall ist
das hier das foto vom bmw und er
schreibt hat das ist ein trauriger bmws
weil der halt auch irgendwie ein
bisschen traurig ist ja aber wenn ich
den fans mit
ich würde ich dir schreibt eine person
namens luca hai gilt das angebot noch
liebe grüße bitte einmal anständig dafür
bewerben sehr geehrter mein name ist
luca und ich habe schon mein ganzes
leben davon geträumt ihre nintendos
switch abkaufen zu können bei der
besonderen stärken sind kreativität
leistungsfähigkeit ehrgeiz teamfähigkeit
und kreativität das thema kreativität
geschrieben das hat 11 einfach wirklich
von mir kommen können ich freue mich
schon auf unsere zukünftige gemeinsame
transaktion bis bald und mit
freundlichen grüßen luca des vereins
salzig sein können ich würde sagen dass
wir nun auch schon zum letzten mal fällt
für heute kommen und zwar ist es dieser
hier danke erst mal für ihre antwort
sehr verspätet aber danke erst einmal
finde ich es um verschiedene und
ziemlich unprofessionell dass sie sich
so spät melden
mein mann und ich haben nun schon eine
andere wohnung mit freundlichen grüßen
also ganz kurz vor dem hintergrund
jemand hat seine wohnung mietet und sich
nicht mehr gemeldet und dann meinte er
na das geht ja gar nicht dass sie so
lange ich melden und blablabla glaube
ich ziemlich selbst erklärte auf jeden
fall antwortet dann der vermieter von
der wohnung hallo frau blablabla vielen
dank für ihre rückmeldung es freut mich
sehr für sie dass sie eine neue wohnung
gefunden haben
davon habe ich tatsächlich schon gehört
grüßen sie doch bitte bei gelegenheit
ganz herzlich den bus von mir vielen
dank im voraus und eine schöne woche
welchem bus die mit den leuten die es
interessiert sie wissen dass es gerade
für sie beamtenbeleidigung bedeutet ich
bin beamten nur zur info kommt kevin
oder annette oder hildegard auch immer
solche und albern sein komplett heißen
pack deine sachen gehen diesen bus
fahren nach bosnien die 15 bosnien die
15 stunden an kannst ist das wlan dinge
mitbringen auf dem rückweg
regelmäßig cookies